everyone is saying that the 14 plus has
the best battery life with the best
battery life ever in an iPhone I thought
that too but we were wrong and I'll
explain why along with multiple
surprises I found with this new budget
large iPhone I was surprised that after
about 20 minutes of watching YouTube the
14 pro Max was still at 100 while the 14
plus was at 97 and after about 35
minutes the max finally dropped down to
99 and the plus hit 96 but I was curious
if the difference because of promotion
which can drop the screen's refresh rate
to match the video really makes it that
big of a difference or if apple is
calculating these phones differently
which I'll cover in just a bit for the
first half I was on cellular which is
why I went to connect under the line to
make this as real world as possible and
when I got to our office I switched to
Wi-Fi like I normally would next I spent
about a half hour going through emails
text and social media like I do most
mornings which caused the 14 pro Max to
drop by 7 seven percent from 99 to 92
whereas the plus dropped by 6 to 90. see
most battery tests are fake or at least
done in a lap setting which makes it
easier but I wanted to make the most
real world battery life comparison I
have ever seen so I set up both phones
identically using iCloud backup and I
logged into all of my apps which a lot
of them use location services background
app refresh Bluetooth and more I even
paired an Apple Watch to each phone so I
can get notifications through those
which felt really awkward having two
watches on but it helped me find a
peculiar difference for my next hour or
so I set both down and I got to work and
of course the max is always on display
stays on which makes it much easier to
see notifications that come up but it
does use more battery I finished up with
a 20 minute phone call 10 minutes on
each phone to make it perfectly fair and
during that time the pro Max used more
battery life than the plus with both
phones having the same 87 battery life
after about two and a half hours of
being unplugged but what's really weird
is that the max would show every
notification even if it came to the
connected Apple watch whereas the 14
plus wouldn't light up if I got the text
on my watch or if it popped up on my
computer but for emails both would light
up and I noticed that the 14 plus lights
up a lot brighter than the max but it
also shuts off quickly so I would have
to periodically check to see if I missed
anything just like I would in the real
world if I didn't have the always-on
display this is one of my issues with
most of the battery comparisons online
now I respect the amount of hard work
and time but those tests don't account
for though always on displays background
tasks or extra brightness which people
do make use of after that I tossed both
phones in my pocket which turns off the
always-on display on the Max and a bit
later I headed outside to meet my family
and yes I shot this 4K video clip on
both phones as for this test I was
meticulous to do everything exactly the
same on both and when I got in my truck
the pro Max had lost less battery just
just one percent when it's in your
pocket and always on display is off now
I use Google Maps for navigation which
uses the GPS and the cellular which by
the way only the pro Max with the a16
has the new more efficient Snapdragon
x65 modem which at times shows less bars
but still has faster speeds while at
other times with 5G it has better
reception than the 14 pro which uses the
same modem from the iPhone 13s when I
arrived about 35 minutes later the 14
plus lost 25 more battery going from 85
down to 73 whereas the pro Max was more
efficient going from 86 down to 77 which
really surprised me because in this test
I was using auto brightness the whole
time unlike other people's comparisons
and I use auto brightness the whole time
throughout this video which is what most
people do and even Apple hides that
toggle in the settings whereas with
Android you can easily find it with that
the 14 pro Max has that new display
which can hit 2 000 nits out doors
compared to 1200 nits on the 14 plus
when I was setting everything up I once
again noticed that the 14 pro series
consistently has higher auto brightness
in the same exact scenarios than the 14
line which does use more power now some
people said that the iPhone will Auto
calibrate to the brightness that I
prefer after about a week or so but it
has been about three weeks and is still
brighter than the older generation
sometimes too bright the 14 plus on the
other hand was fairly good most of the
time just sometimes slightly too dark
and when either phone was too dark or
too bright I would adjust them to my
liking just like I would in real world
use but 75 of the time or so I'll just
leave it as is since even if the max was
slightly too bright or the plus was
slightly too dark most people just
wouldn't touch it I'll go over how much
of a difference that extra brightness
makes but first if you are still
browsing the open web you should be
protected by VPN like our sponsor
private internet access which basically
changes your IP address and reroutes
your internet traffic through through an
encrypted tunnel to hide and protect
your online activity from your ISP the
network admin and the government on all
of our devices so hackers can't see your
keystrokes passwords access files or
internet activity and the best feature
is that pia has 50 servers in 50 states
as well as many other countries so you
can access content that's not available
where you live or even watch a
television premiere before it becomes
available in your time zone private
internet access is also the most
customizable VPN on the market another
world's most transparent VPN provider
with over 30 million downloads and they
never record or store any user data so
go ahead and click the link in the
description and pin comment to get up to
82 off and get an extra three months
free and don't worry signing up is
risk-free with a 30-day money-back
guarantee so check out Pia today for the
next few hours I spent time with my
family my kids had Jiu Jitsu so I took
some 4K videos as well as photos on both
of the phones and some of that time I
spent checking in on email else in
social media we also went out to eat so
I was using my phone as normal and for
the photos I took I remembered that the
Promax has to do a lot more processing
for photos and video with its 48
megapixel main camera which drains more
battery and it did because the Promax
dropped by 12 whereas the plus dropped
by 10. afterwards we headed home where I
connected airpods to both phones and
even though it is a pain I synced both
phones to play into separate ears so
while I was doing normal chores around
the house I could listen to podcasts
this time the Promax lost 5 instead of
seven likely because they were in my
pocket with the always on display turned
off now it's time for a bit of fun and I
made sure that all the settings were the
same and I had the HD Graphics Pack
downloaded no and I played Cod mobile
for about 45 minutes with the displays
at 80 brightness and neither phones got
too hot but the Promax did use slightly
more battery resulting in a lead of
three percent now even though the a16 is
more powerful I noticed that it does a
good job with background tasks likely
because of its efficiency cores that are
more powerful and more efficient so the
performance cores don't have to be used
as often for some late night
productivity I usually love to have
videos open in the background while I
get work done and this time the displays
are dimmer than usual and after a solid
hour and a half the Promax drained nine
percent battery instead of 11 on the
plus this is where I have to add that
with the latest iOS update which was
installed on both I have definitely been
noticing better battery life with my 14
pro Max even though I complained about
it in the past I think a lot of it was
just a really buggy version of iOS now I
finished up the night with an HDR movie
which pushes the pro Max more and I set
the phones down at 12 30 with a four
percent lead on the max now that is not
a big difference but to be honest I
thought the 14 plus would be 10 to 15
ahead at this point because it does have
a larger battery a dimmer screen and no
always on display when I get up six
hours later the plus own only drained
four percent while the max drained six
and I did my usual routine starting with
some reading emails social media and
then why I got ready I listened to some
more YouTube videos before heading out
of the house which dropped both phones
by the same 15 by the time I left the
house I headed to a meeting where I used
the phones for notes and scheduling and
once I got back to the office we were
under 10 on both I left both of them on
to keep up with stocks as well as social
media and the plus started dropping like
a rock down to two percent and I don't
think that it's only promotion it seems
like the pro max sits at a hundred
percent a lot longer and also holds up
better under 10 percent so I'm guessing
that Apple has set up the battery drain
indicator the percentage differently on
both phones and then just after 11 the
plus died with the Promax having five
percent battery remaining so no even
without the extra power sucking features
the Plus does not last longer under a
real world use but what shocked me was
how much longer the pro Max lasted I
used it to airdrop videos and photos
reply to some texts and emails and it
was still not dead I set up a camera to
record when it dies and even though it
was still getting notifications it
lasted until 12 15 about an hour and 10
minutes longer than the plus and you
could say that this test wasn't fair
because I didn't lock the brightness to
the same level like many people do I use
the always-on display and the other
features but even then the pro Max beat
out the 14 plus and I thought my test
would be giving a huge lead to the plus
where others lock it all down I think
what I wasn't expecting is that the new
4 nanometer a16 processor uses a lot
less power for those simple tasks that
we usually do throughout the day and it
also sips power for background usage
that and the new modem practically
offset the extra drain from the new
display and features which also means if
you turn that off and you use manual
brightness the battery life difference
will be even greater so there you guys
go if you enjoy this video you like the
real world type testing and the effort
that goes along with it click that
Circle above to subscribe to see more
videos like this one and check out one
of those great videos right over there
that's been Max and I'll see you in the
next one
[Music]